we've got new warnings straight from the
covet front lines as there are fears
that labor day travel could lead to
another spike in cases more than 5.3
million travelers were screened by tsa
officers over the holiday even as the
average daily death count from kova
jumped 130 percent over the last month
now that's the worst it's been since
march before the vaccines were widely
available our lead national
correspondent that is david bagno just
visited a texas hospital where staff are
struggling really struggling to keep up
david good morning to you this is so
troubling it is gail about a week ago we
told you the story of daniel wilkinson
the u.s army veteran who died in a texas
hospital last month he died because he
couldn't get access to the specialized
care that he needed in time to save his
life all of the hospitals that could
save him were full of covet patients so
we went back to talk to that er doctor
that tried to save him dr hassan cackley
and what we found was a caregiver
furious and frustrated that he can't get
people the care they need
in the time they need it
kovid is kicking humanity's ass
and as a member as a team player on team
human team humanity
i take that personally this is dr hassan
cackley he is in a race against time but
right now he is losing
it's okay
his patient 50-year-old arisely has been
unresponsive since he admitted her to el
campo memorial hospital roughly three
days ago it's okay she needs an icu bed
and an evaluation from a cancer
specialist el campo has neither
despite being just 76 miles from houston
home to the world's largest medical
complex and more than 85 different
hospitals dr cackley can't find one that
will accept her as a transfer everyone
is overwhelmed with covet patients i
tried to get her into the to the best
cancer hospital
in the world which is also in houston
and um
[Music]
they couldn't take her
cackley told us the wait times here in
the er are unprecedented you would never
see four digits on minutes since checked
in
where four digits on the thousands of
minutes
we've never
seen this
ever but dr cackley understands what the
other hospitals are facing here in el
campo their beds are almost entirely
filled with covet patients too so 20
patients in the hospital only one does
not have covert
wow
that's how it's been
past three weeks wow every day
like tell them annie every day every day
for nearly four days he and his team
have worked the phones nurse virginia
broman called almost every hospital in
houston alrighty thank you
bye-bye
no they don't have any beds while dr
cackley called md anderson cancer
hospital and he pressed them politely at
this point it's kind of like we need
help like if she if she didn't have the
malignancy
and we had an open icu bed we would take
care of her here finally he got it a yes
they accepted araceli i thought you'd be
all jubilant and no i'm not jubilant
because it shouldn't take four days and
five phone calls to make this happen
it's sad that
like we're all relieved and happy that
we finally got a patient out
after four
days like that's where the bar is right
now
like we got him out eventually
and kudos to the entire staff here the
other er docs the other staff that have
been kept keeping this patient alive
for as long as we have if we get through
this like
the team that we have here like our bond
and everything that we have is just
going to be that much stronger
if we get through this if we don't kill
each other exactly
if we don't kill each other first we'll
be good it was one of the few times they
laughed together that day
but the good feelings did not last for
long five covet patients walked into the
er while we were there and none of them
were vaccinated
one more question
how are you
um
how am i
i'm still going
i've had to accept the worst possible
case scenario that this is the worst
possible scenario it's not going to get
any better
but we're going to keep
going and that's it
all right let's get to it
that's a good man dr kackley told us
that in order to keep patients alive he
and his team are having to do medical
procedures and treatments they don't
they don't normally do they're not
trained for this they're operating
beyond the scope of their usual
protocols and training typically they
move a patient before some of those
procedures and they get them in and out
of the er within 24 hours they simply
can't do it
and you know you asked while we were
watching the piece are they angry at
these people i never saw them angry they
resigned you know he did say to me at
one point he goes stop telling us that
we shouldn't treat unvaccinated patients
that's not gonna happen yeah we're
always gonna treat them we're gonna move
on we have an oath we have a duty people
say when we can get back to normal we're
not going to get back to normal until
our hospitals are functioning normally
and those doctors are shell-shocked yeah
but i certainly feel their frustration
because they know it doesn't have to be
this bad if people get vaccinated of
course they're going to treat them
because that's what that is their job
and they're going to do that yeah
individuals like him they're titled
essential workers
but a more fitting word is heroes bingo
david thank you so much